HIM TO REESTABLISH HIMSELF IN
THE NATIONAL HOCKEY 6-2 WIN.
HE KULAK.
ON THE AND QUICKLY THROUGH
CENTER
THE CANADIENS HOLD THE LINE.
THEN THE
THERE.
WHETHER IT WAS DEFLECTED. IT OV
COULDN'T GET PALMIERI AND THEY
GO THE OTHER WAY TO FIND LOOK.
SEES PARISE IN FRONT.
LITTLE DEFLECTION, BUT LOOK WHA.
DOBSON'S GOING T TORY.
>> Butch: BOTH TEAMS A LITTLE
SLOPPY IN THEO FIND
A MAN ON THE FAR SIDE.
PLAY IT BACK  THE BACK GLASS.
SUSAN
SUZUKI, THE GOES
SHORT SIDED AND SOROKIN4-1.
ISLANDPASS BY CLAGUE IN HIS OWN
HIT A BOOT.
CAME R
ALLOWS TWO!
LOOK WHERE HE IS.ECKING GUYS OU.
THEY'RE WANTING TO MAK THE GAME
>> Butch: YOU LOOK PAGEAU.
JOINED BY PARISE UP OAT IT IN F
SIT TOWARDS CENTER POINT.
TO GET BEHIND BEAUVILLIER.
STOPPED ON A DIME.
WHAT A ON THE BACKYORK.
ISLANDERS ONLY ONETITO.
THIS YO.
HE'S Autch: SEE IF HE GOES WITH
THE SLOW UP SCENARIO.
THAT MADE THEND THREE TO
KEEP THE GAME ALIVE.
>> Butch: I LIKE THE MOVE.
COME IN WITH SPEED, GET A FAKE.
CUTTING RIGHT.
SHOOTSTS